[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم ايجاز من غرفه اخبار الجزيره
اهلا بكم خلال قمتها الطارئه في ابوجا
مجموعه دول غرب افريقيا تدعو الى الافراج
الفوري عن رئيس النيجر المحتز واعادته
للسلطه وتفرض حظر سفر وتجميد اصول على
المسؤولين العسكريين الضالعين بالانقلاب
مؤيدون للانقلاب يهاجمون السفاره الفرنسيه
في النيجر وباريس تردد وتلوح برد فوري اذا
تعرض اي من رعايه هذه هجمات
في تجدد للاشتباكات بمخيم عين الحلوه
للاجئين الفلسطينيين في جنوب لبنان مقتل
خمسه اشخاص بينهم قائد الامن الوطني
الفلسطيني لمنطقه صيدا العميد ابو اشرف
العرموشي بعد مغادرته الاجتماع الامني كان
مخصصا للبحث في التوتر الذي يشهده المخيم
رئيس الوزراء البولنديه يقول ان مئه من
مقاتل مجموعه تاجنار المنتشرين في
بيلاروسيا تحركوا باتجاه حدود بلاده واصفا
الوضع بانه بالغ الخطوره ومشيرا الى ان
المقاتلين الروس سيتنكرون على الارجح في
زي حرس حدود بيلاروسيا وسيساعدون
المهاجرين غير النظاميين في دخول اراضي
بلاده لزعزعه استقرارها
في اليوم العالمي لمكافحه للتجاره بالبشر
الامم المتحده تقول ان عدد الضحايا حول
العالم بلغ نحو 28 مليونا وتطلق حمله
دوليه لمساعدتهم وتقول ان الازمه العالميه
والصراعات تسببت في تفاقم مخاطر لتجاره
بالبشر الى اللقاء